[Music]
are you nervous no we got two shelves in
a regular and extra crispy okay I never
thought of myself as a roast comic Jay
was back in his element cracking jokes
about the frightening accident that left
him with third degree burns stay away
from the Flaming Hot Doritos
the comedian stand-up routine in Hermosa
Beach lasted just over an hour how'd it
feel it's good thanks guys his burn
scars were barely visible and his
comeback was pretty triumphant well
except for this
listen again
yep that's the sound of the rear right
tire on Jay's Tesla grazing the tire of
a police car Jake Master something on
the way in you hit no damage on either
car well you really hit a car
no there's no damage on your car over
there see that there you go it's like a
miracle again
these are the two guys from adam12
they're not real cops no they're not
it's a remake of item 12 though
comedian Arsenio Hall who opened for
Lino told E.T after Jay is an amazing
guy no comic would leave the Grossman
Burn Center and do stand-up Sunday in
Hermosa anything you want to say to the
nurses and doctors oh no they were great
they're really good Lino says he wants
to throw a benefit to support burn
victims who can't afford care we'll give
you the strength to get up there again
what gave me the strength there's no
strings you just tell stupid jokes thank
you guys see you later